papin au chapitre musique maintenant
avec discrétion et talent alain chamfort
propose son douzième album personne
n'est parfait c'est son titre et c'est
sans doute le meilleur enregistrement
jamais proposé par celui que l'on
appelle parfois le dandy de la chanson
française stéphane haumant didier
rancoeur je suis chanteur de variétés je
n'avais pas entré dans le port voilà
manureva oui c'est tellement c'était
votre chanson préférée à boncelles de
votre mère et revoilà son ford envie d
abuser ironique éternel séducteur
à propos vous avez été toujours chez vos
parents ce n'est que lui
un bébé chanteur arrivé à maturité est
capable de se moquer de sa propre image
c'était amusant d'exprimer sans une
chanson savoir qu'on n'est pas du couac
à la fois on joue au chanteur on est
content de mer et puis et puis aussi que
ça peut avoir un instinct fait ridicule
et que avec faut pas l'oublier quoi
personne n'est parfait son douzième
album est comme la synthèse de tous les
autres un mélange d'influencés
marquantes claude françois au début et
serge gainsbourg pour passage
oh
viens me
chang
tous
kerry
du tout
moi j'ai un rapport à la mélodie à la
chanson qui besoin aussi que par moment
d'être pas naïve gérer mais mettrait
très simple comme ça une chanson qui
nous prend un peu fait ce type qui
pénètre facilement le l'oreille qui est
agréable à entendre qu'il ya un effet
assez immédiat tout ça mais j'ai
toujours bien aimé ça quoi
à bientôt 50 ans en forez toujours
d'écrire un standard une chanson reprise
dans le monde entier pour laisser itil
une belle trappe
un peu moins politique la bourse